[Music]
[Applause]
Charles Barkley Hall of Famer TNT inside
the NBA analyst boy who was the happiest
person in Boston last night that the
Celtics got to win and well they uh held
up your vacation there Charles
yeah yeah that the easy game last night
though Dan you knew they were gonna win
that game the fun starts tomorrow in
Miami that was the easiest bet I've ever
made you know they were going to ride to
momentum after game four
um they were going to be rockers in that
building uh that was an easy game now
the fun starts tomorrow when you go on
the road and it's do or die what do you
expect
well you know the second's got a better
team uh I mean I think everybody can see
that if they played their best in Miami
play their best they got a better team
but man they keep having this these
lapses
um like I say the better team if if the
Celtics lose this series they still with
a better team they just have too many
brain lapses
I think they're going to keep it
together and win I think we're going to
go back to Boston for game seven yeah I
do too I just think they're Front
Runners
uh when things are going good they're
great
but I would love to see them or they
wouldn't make it all their threes and
have to learn to do other things to win
the game and that's where your mental
toughness comes in when you have to
scrap play defense and really really
hustle I love to see that but
I I think they they're going to play
well tomorrow
yeah it's frustrating because when I see
the Celtics play like they did last
night the last two games that's the way
they played during the regular season
and you see Miami wasn't consistent
during the regular season and now I
don't know what to expect out of Boston
and that has to be frustrating for
everybody involved with this team
yeah because you know they have to brain
fart against the Hawks they did the same
thing against the Sixers and
I was watching TV 97 of the people
picked the Celtics to win I'm like yeah
that's a no-brainer you know Miami can't
make it interesting because they play
hard they play smart Jimmy's terrific
but acceptance got the best team
and you see the stage you're like well
that's why they've been consistent
inconsistent all year
uh but they live and die by the three
and like I say I if they're making
threes they're gonna be tough to beat
but
shooting a basketball is the hardest
part of the game and I love to see them
not make threes and see how tough they
were mentally because you saw how weak
they were mentally in game
game three
uh when they don't like they came down
and missed like 10 threes in a row and
just really just quit
uh I think and I actually think that's
really the one thing that really hurt
the Miami Heat
what Magic Johnson saying they quit me
saying they quit they had to come out in
game four and play good
and then they got hot
so that that that's probably the work
they had a loss of really competitive
game in game three I think they would
have got swept but they played so bad in
game three they had to play for any
problem you got on the Celtic jersey and
the way they played in game four and
then I said Jason got hot in game four
and it carried over to game five yeah
these teams can shoot themselves back
into a game but also shoot themselves
out of a game because everybody's so
reliant on the three would you rather
have Jason Tatum or Jimmy Butler as your
teammate
Jimmy Butler I know he gonna give it to
me he's tough he got he got that that
grip
Jason Tatum probably is a better player
but you asked me who I want to go on the
Foxhole with it's going to be Jimmy
Butler
yeah but but there's a lot of guys who
are great players here like
I don't want to go into Foxhole with
that guy uh from my generation
uh but to answer your question uh Jason
Tatum's probably a better player but if
I'm gonna go to war I want Jimmy Butler
as my sidekick talking to Charles
Barkley Inside the NBA analyst and of
course Hall of Famer do you think LeBron
really feels like there's now he said
he's better than 90 to 95 percent of the
players so let's say he's better than 95
percent so that's a little over 20 guys
does LeBron think there are 20 guys
better than him right now in the NBA
probably not when you're a great player
like he is your ego
makes you think you're always the best
but
first of all Lebron's not gonna retire
no
I was disappointed he brought that up in
the nuggets
highlight of their organization you know
they'd never been to the finals that
just swept the big bad Lakers nobody's
giving them any respect but do you think
he did it strategically Charles because
LeBron is very chunky yes yes because
you know them fools don't ask when we're
going to talk about it
on like they still talking about it you
know it's funny I actually Dan I
actually turn my television off the next
day because the first two blocks
we're all about LeBron instead of what
the Denver Nuggets has accomplished I
mean you think about they got a dude on
their team who's
arguably could have won three MVPs in a
row
had just swept the big bad Lakers
and we they spend the first two blocks
talk about if LeBron gonna retire yeah I
think he did it intentionally there's no
way he's retiring
I just uh LeBron's such a good dude and
yeah he got his stuff together I was
disappointed he took the shine away from
the Nuggets because what they have
accomplished you know it's crazy Dan
when the playoffs started you go back I
mean how much this thing has changed in
two weeks two weeks is all we're really
talking about
two weeks ago was boy I used to be Steph
Curry put up 50. those Warriors got
their Championship DNA they're the team
to beat in the Western Conference you
know that's what Champions do
then
the the Nuggets play the signs like man
and Katie and really Booker and KD gave
it to the Clippers they're like man
the Nuggets gonna be get beat by the
Suns
and then next thing you know they lose
they beat the the Sun and then the
Lakers the big bad Lakers with LeBron
and Andrew Davis beat the Warriors like
oh
this is is this gonna be LeBron's best
Championship ever
it's gonna be a great story why why are
you watching
I I heard a couple guys like wow can you
believe it this team was two and ten at
the beginning of the season they were in
the play-in now they're gonna play for
the championship and and Joker says
smack them four quick times
and we don't even celebrate damn they've
been in first place since October yeah
the Lakers got hot after the trade
deadline
they got all those good players after
the trade deadline
the maggots been in first place since
October
why do you keep watching ESPN
well I'm on the treadmill I gotta watch
something because you know I can't watch
your punk ass kill Bayless
I gotta watch
I gotta watch ESPN it's the only thing
to make your workouts go faster
what do you weigh okay over under
Charles right now uh what What's the uh
over under Paulie oh man he looks good I
would have said the over at 279 and a
half okay who's going over or under Marv
Barkley over 279 and a half under Paulie
just over
seating under
yeah I'm under two on that I'm going
under 279 and a half Chuck
you're wrong
um you know Dan I started at 3 52.
uh in January I've been taking this drug
drug called monjiro and I've been
working out
and I tipped the scales the other day at
290. all right so I can't you know I was
talking to my doctor she's awesome
I can't get back to my plan weight which
is 250. so my goal is 270. but I started
out when I started taking this drug
Manjaro
uh I was too man because she didn't like
ozone I think she liked you so I don't
like those Epic try Manjaro
and like I say I waited the other day
and I was 290. I feel great I'm gonna
get to 270
I got to figure out because at some
point I got to get off the drug but I
really feel so good physically I got to
make sure I don't get fat again because
you don't even realize how crappy you
feel until you start losing weight
that's the thing that's funny
no I mean I was like I feel so good now
but you don't even realize like I said
you don't even realize how crappy you
feel
until you start losing weight so I
appreciate the love for you guys who's
lost more weight you or Shaq
I don't know uh how much he's lost he
looks he looks good but I don't think
he's in close
to me
yeah but Shaq was up to four spins right
where did you go Dan I'm right here
I think it's on your end
you're Frozen
there you go
okay yeah
Shaq was up to four spins wasn't he
oh easily golly
easily
um hey I was uh we had Tim legler on and
I said who's your player cop with Joker
and he said I don't have one
and he said there's no game plan for him
he said Denver's winning no matter who
they play in the finals because of Joker
Is there a player comp for Joker that
you played against
that's a great question he's right
whoever dealer plays they're going to
win they'll have a much easier time with
the heat than the Celtics though yeah
um but I think Denver I haven't changed
my pick since the playoffs started the
devil nuggets are going to win the World
Championship
he he's the best pastor big man
I've seen since Bill Walton and Brad
Doherty
but those guys couldn't shoot threes
and I don't think either one of them
were as great in the poster as Joker
okay
I mean he's man he's unbelievable and
then there's no way you can't like him
you like if you don't like him it's
something wrong with you
I mean if you don't like the Joker
there's something wrong with you as a
person and just that little thing he did
when he went up to Matt ishma and gave
him a hug
that's the Joker man he's such a great
kid he don't and he don't have no bells
and whistles
he just plays basketball he plays smart
but you got to give that GM a lot of
credit going out and getting some kcp
brown the little brown brown kid from
Kansas
I mean man he's done a phenomenal job I
think his name is Calvin booth they are
loaded and
man I can't wait to see what happens
because
you know I'm not one of these guys I
want to see I love guys who on the crap
list with me who are great players who
haven't won a championship I really
would love to see Joker win it because
he's never going to get his due until he
wins the championship that's just the
way this thing works out now yeah so I
would love to see him win the
championship because
it doesn't make or break your life if
you don't win the championship I know
some people want you to think that I
mean I'm pretty damn sure I'm doing good
then
um but does Shaq think he's getting to
you when he brings up that you didn't
win
all right I don't think he's that dumb
you know how many titles he won in
Orlando before he got together with Kobe
or D Wade
yeah I know you know I always laugh it's
like I didn't realize what basketball
became like tennis and golfer individual
sport yeah you know like it thing is
crazy like Joker's been the best player
really probably for the last three or
four years the only difference is Jamal
Murray got healthy and he's got a
sidekick now they best clearly is better
but it's the team game I always laugh
when people say that to me I'm like I'm
not sure what you want me to do if you
want me to get mad I'm not going to get
mad yeah I get it I didn't win the
championship but I it's like things like
I I I get it appreciate it but uh I
always laugh when somebody says it to me
what's the oddest endorsement you've
ever been offered
that's a great question
I don't I don't consider I am very
selective
because I wanna
build a partnership I can't remember the
weirdest one to be honest with you Dan
but I'm very strategic
on the companies I involved myself with
it's something uh they really have to I
have to really trust them
uh and they have to help me do things in
the community uh to be honest with you
because I don't look at like I don't
want to just make money
uh I just think it's important that they
help me in the community especially
communities of color
and really poverty because it's more
people who are poured in it who are
black because white people there are a
lot of white people out there just as
poor as black people anybody who want to
level the playing field they can work
with me uh because obviously I'm black
and I want to help the black community
but also want to help poor white people
also
um they need just as much help because
you know people always talk about race
but the really big problem is economic
opportunities
Before I Let You Go uh we've been
playing Marvin's been playing uh his uh
playlist for a cookout and I didn't know
if you had a a song like a go-to song
that you want played at a cookout
Well my two favorite groups are the
Eagles and Public Enemy
I've seen the Eagles probably
45 to 50 times
Public Enemy is my favorite rap group of
all time
anytime you get Eagles or Public Enemy
at a cookout I'm golden but you gotta
make sure you burn the hot dogs Dan
that's the most important thing
it's got to be crispy hot dogs and you
can only put onions and ketchup on them
and they got to be raw onions and
ketchup maybe sometimes I'll throw a
little spicy mustard but the most
important thing is to get the hot dog
crispy and onions I don't think Public
Enemy and the Eagles ever played they
didn't tour together I don't think I
don't think they played no I think
they're going for two demographics
demographics
did you ever were you ever uh stricken
by the South Beach flu when you played
that's one of the stupidest things
it they're like Miami's been
you know if you know what's really
stupid everybody talks about Denver like
you can't breathe in Denver I'm like
maybe my memory is a little fuzzy but I
don't remember the devil nugget just
stacking up championships after
Championship because of the altitude
that's like please stop no listen man in
the NBA you get to sleep all day the
game doesn't start till 7 30 at night
you got plenty of time the the heat it's
amazing when they had Dwyane Wade Alonzo
bun and Shaquille they won the
championship when they had Dwyane Wade
LeBron and Chris Bosh they won the
championship what exactly happened those
other years they didn't have those guys
so you never you never had the South
Beach flu you never went out too late
and it hung over the next game yeah yeah
well I had a lot more in other states
well okay what was what was your go-to
City where you go this could be a long
night
well anytime you went to LA New York
it's it's intoxicating because when
you're in L.A literally literally you
got all these Stars around
you know and it's it also when you go to
New York
I was always amazed when I went to New
York you'd go out it's three or four
o'clock in the morning and you're like
don't these people have a job
I mean I'm always laughing and it's like
damn it's crazy
there was a place in New York called
butter
we used to drive up on Monday night just
to go there it would ever I met Paige I
met Eli there one night for the first
time every there was probably 20 Stars
at the bar
but there was still like hundreds of
people and you said to yourself
well we're stars and we know who we are
do these people have jobs
but it always amazed me in New York when
you go any night of the week like every
obviously when you go out on a Friday or
Saturday in any City there's going to be
a lot of people but I don't care what
night you went out in New York
Philadelphia was the same way
there's a place every Sunday night every
Monday night we used to go out too uh
and he's like well we know what we got
to do tomorrow what these other people
ain't got no jobs it's crazy
you think you could have survived in New
York planned for the the Knicks
oh yeah because when you go there
that adrenaline that you know that's the
reason they call it the best arena in
the world man even when you went there
on a bad team there's so much juice in
the building you get energy to tell you
and then when you sit over there same
thing in L.A when you see all those
Stars sitting over there
you want to play I remember the first
time my first game in L.A Jack Nicholson
said hello to me I wouldn't call my mom
Jack Nicholson know who I am I couldn't
believe it you know he said right beside
the bench he gave me a compliment I
would have told all my friends I called
my mom and grandma y'all not gonna
believe this Jack Nicholson know who I
am hey same thing Denzel Washington came
up to me one time Dan
you know and I try hard not to Fanboy
but I was so excited I'm like didn't say
Washington know who Chuck is it's crazy
they all know who you are now have a
great summer hopefully you get started
soon here
you know we were talking about I was
talking to Ernie about it last night
going into game four
we're like guys we're 15 minutes away
basically
from vacation vacation yeah and now five
days later we might have to work
uh I think you're going to hey uh thanks
as always I hope you have a great off
season we'll try not to bother you and
uh thanks again hey man I appreciate you
Dan and tell the guys I said hello y'all
have a great holiday and thanks to all
the soldiers and everybody who's ever
served thank you all right that's
Charles Barkley we'll take a break we're
back after this